[Applause]
that is a massive migrant caravan
traveling through mexico they're
chanting si se puedo or yes we can as
they're trekking toward the united
states one thousand texas troopers and
rangers have been sent down to our
southern border they're bracing for that
arrival texas congressman tony gonzalez
says president biden can fix this at any
moment but he chooses illegal
immigration over fixing the broken
system and he joins us now good morning
congressman
hey good morning easley good morning i
mean holy cow when we saw those images
yesterday a massive caravan coming to
america what do you think about this
because you're a texas resident
yeah no the biden administration just
continues on this illegal immigration
route and all it's doing is encouraging
more and more people to make this the
sad part about it is this caravan that
we're seeing of thousands of people is
only the shiny object underneath that
these these folks aren't controlled by
the cartel these are kind of a local
organization that has put these together
so what you're not seeing is the
thousands of folks that are run by the
cartel continue to make it over our
southern border it's only going to get
worse until this administration stands
up and does something you know
congressman when we see these images
yesterday we had griff jenkins in the
crowd and he was showing us people in
wheelchairs lots of kids in strollers of
course our heart breaks for them we
understand how much they want to be in
america because by the grace of god we
were born here many of us have come here
and done it the right way isn't there a
better way to do it though
there is absolutely a better way to do
it and you know the sad part is instead
of this administration focusing on legal
immigration reform which i think a lot
of people especially on the republican
side are open to the discussion on legal
immigration they have chosen to go down
the illegal immigration route just look
at the the reconciliation package you
know kevin mccarthy last week held a a
round table to discuss it and in this
reconciliation package is amnesty for
about 10 million folks which is
completely the wrong approach what isn't
in this reconciliation package a package
of trillions of dollars is nothing for
border patrol zero for border patrol
they're ignoring it so when you when
when we hear that the texas rangers and
texas police officers they're heading a
thousand of them are heading down to the
border
we see those images of what they did in
tapachuli yesterday they ran right
through the mexican national guard how
do we know they're not going to do that
to our men and women that are down there
at the border
yeah texas has been alone on this fight
from the beginning the federal
government joe biden is nowhere to be
seen i mean he won't make it to the
border he won't send anyone else to the
border as well so texas is on its own
for the first time though i think you
see
texans get behind texans and we're ready
to secure our border on our own sadly
that's what it's come to you know you've
got texas national guard there you've
got of course dps agents as well the
bottom line is people regular everyday
people do not feel safe because of the
chaos that this administration is
causing i'm watching the images right
now congressman this is what's coming to
america thank you so much for being on
with us we appreciate all your service
and what you do for our country
thank you ashley you're welcome i'm
steve ducey i'm brian killme and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis